you
I'm Xena Badawi and welcome to the Kings
library and welcome to all our noble
laureates I'll be talking to them about
themselves and also the role of science
in society today gentlemen
congratulations to you all thank you I
don't see any lady amongst you so that's
why I say gentlemen so I want to ask you
now all of you tell me honestly are you
quite satisfied about being in the
limelight scientists like this Nobel
time occupying center stage so what well
if you've ever wondered what it was like
to be famous I can report that for one
week it's a it's a lot of fun but I'm
just betting that for this group of
people that will be really glad that
it's only for one week I don't think any
of us would want to be Brad Pitt what
about you breathe I'd have to agree
exactly with saw it's a very new
experience it's not unpleasant but
probably I'd like to get some work done
pretty soon yeah its life in the fast
lane oh I've given a driver name stick
which is pretty entertaining
but I'll be happy to I think get off the
road and get back to work for myself
I've been a bit uncomfortable but I love
the attention that it's brought to my
colleagues and to my field of science
Danny I mean are you enjoying it come on
you're not all shy retiring scientists
in that's like to stay in your
laboratory time it's good for you to be
like this in the spotlight shy but I
enjoy it very much but the question is
okay so now we have some powers we did
not have before the question is what do
you do with it
now we have access to decision-makers at
least I have access to decision-makers
and and the question is will I use it
properly I try - okay well we'll find
out some more about that Thomas what do
you think I disagree with so if I could
look like Brad Pitt I would enjoy it
you could amorphous brain as well but
don't yourself trade everything don't
get yourself down Thomas Christopher
your fellow economist well I think that
the access the decision-makers is not
such a big deal for us as economists
since our
has already influenced the people are
making decisions about my economic
policy but winning the Nobel does give
you a chance to be heard by ordinary
people more in venues like this and
that's a good thing isn't it Jule well I
would say that I feel a little bit
intimidated more than comfortable but I
would say like Hugh that I'm very I'm
delighted that the fields on which we
have worked and also the co-workers have
been recognized by this price and I also
feel a sense of responsibility as you've
said so what's the heart goes on